resurge la esperanza en la frontera
entre colombia y venezuela la empresa de
transporte de alfredo rosales y sus
hermanos trabajaba a pleno rendimiento
hasta que en 2015 el gobierno de nicolás
maduro cerró los pasos fronterizos con
su vecina colombia tras el deterioro de
las relaciones bilaterales entonces
dejaron de transportar anualmente casi
un millón de toneladas de harina carbón
cemento y otras mercancías ahora con la
promesa del presidente colombiano
gustavo petro de normalizar las
relaciones y reanudar la actividad
comercial binacional los empresarios
tienen esperanza de recuperar sus
camiones y volver a la carretera de ver
unos carros que han producido que ha
entrado tanto y verlo ahí arriba o
pudriéndose
desechando se sólo como se pueden ver
estos carros
y de repente que llegué
la apertura de la frontera otra vez
queda salir adelante de repente hay un
ánimo chico entiende aunque el optimismo
es contenido y en el terreno saben que
la situación no cambiará drásticamente
de la noche a la mañana después del
periodo del conservador iván duque ahora
se abre un nuevo tiempo después de más
de un lustro de tensiones la semana que
viene ya deberíamos tener en principio
empezar a circular aunque sea de manera
simbólica algunos vehículos porque esa
señal es la que va a permitir que los
empresarios empiecen a voltear al otro
lado a ver qué es lo que pueden comprar
del otro lado de reactivar las
autoridades venezolanas estiman que si
la apertura fronteriza se hace efectiva
este mismo año la actividad económica
entre ambas naciones podría alcanzar los
1.200 millones de dólares